all right i think we're up
let's make sure that this is going and
looking
okay
how's everybody doing
so um the big thing
before i get started is
i'm not joking with the name of this
live stream
hang on i always have that
i always mis calculate that
there we go uh i am not kidding
when i say distraction from politics no
election talk
if you talk politics in the chat
if you update me on poll numbers if you
give me anything that has been reported
on it you will get
knocked into timeout and if you keep it
up i will
block you off the channel i am not
messing around
this is meant to be an oasis tonight
all right and like
you should i like i've got something
here i'm not going to
hydrate to the degree
that i did when i watched fan four stick
part of the reason for that is before
this started
uh i went and played cards with my
mother
and uh she poured me a rather
generous uh pour of jack daniels and
maple syrup which if you've never had
it uh together you should but it has to
be real maple syrup
not that garbage that that
corn syrup nonsense but
um i'm i'm already uh a little
happy and i do mean
happy like look regardless of anything
else
for me today has been a good day
and i am determined to end it with
fun with you people
and i am determined that tomorrow i will
find a way to have a good day
no matter what
so jack danny is a maple syrup that
sounds so vermont yeah
it is a bit isn't it so i have
cued up howard the duck
which if you're wondering where i'm
getting it from i have rented it
off of amazon prime it is not expensive
to do so
so and then assuming that uh
howard the duck doesn't kill me which i
did not realize
uh when i decided to do this that it was
an
hour and 50 minutes
assuming that doesn't kill me
we'll move on to uh the 1990
captain america thoughts on titanic
titanic's a good movie
it is it's legitimately a good movie
uh bold of you to assume that it won't
kill you yeah
like i said i'm trying to be optimistic
today
i'm trying to keep a positive vibe
in the universe do you play beer pong oh
dear god no
largely because i refuse to drink beer
if you ever find somebody that sets up a
hard cider pond like
maybe out of morbid curiosity but
otherwise no
uh
i just thought it was that long as well
yeah it's scary
watch the first season of vowel house is
the best show on disney right now i am
gonna start watching that but
i've been i've been waiting for that to
come out to watch it with my kid
so i haven't started it yet because i
want to watch it with her
so you're gonna have to wait for my
thoughts on that thing
uh remember what what kills you makes
you stronger i think i got that right
house tricks tricks are they're not bad
would you rather be tied to a chair
gagged and forced to watch ferris
bueller or the shining
huh
well if i'm gonna be gagged i suppose
shining might get me a little bit more
into a headspace where that
would feel mildly pleasant whereas
ferris bueller would only irritate me
so there you go uh have you watched the
harley quinn
uh show second season i haven't yet
but okay i'm gonna give it uh what time
we got
all right i'm gonna give it one more
minute and then uh we're gonna fire this
stuff up so if you don't have it queued
up already
get it done
uh did you watch the hocus pocus reunion
special i was not aware that that was a
thing that happened
so no no i did not
does anyone else refer to you by your
last name
not since uh when i lived in new york
um because i don't like people
shortening uh
my name and to get around that my
co-workers in new york called me by my
last name which i let slide but that was
the last time anybody really did that
thoughts on clerks watching for the
first time tonight i have not rewatched
clerks in a long time
first time that i watched it kind of
blew my mind
i don't know how i would feel watching
it now
it was a little thing bette midler did
for halloween it was all right oh okay i
mean like
that's fitting the uh the original hocus
pocus was just
all right freaking news alert on my
phone
uh
what does your mother call you when
you're in trouble nothing she just
glares
so oh thank you brian
uh ms wicked wolf if you do that i will
be sorely tempted to ban you off the
channel
so proceed with caution
so that doug jones was back in the
zombie makeup for that hocus pocus thing
okay that might have been more thing all
right well okay i i got i gotta
i gotta start i gotta start this thing
i'm answering questions i gotta start
this so
everybody got it cued up who is watching
it in tandem with me so
three
two one and go
are you a marathon runner dear god no
i i was gearing up to get to a point
where maybe i could have done a 5k
but um i i i'm not
like uh the weather's gotten cold so
i've lapsed on my running
so we had the fbi warning and here we go
oh it's a universal joint
what are we watching we are watching
howard the duck
may rose uh
you let me refer to you by your last
name
like that it's like i mean on any kind
of regular basis is what i meant
this way to start being charming with
that belch i i'm
out of [ __ ] to give
i'll try not to swear too much george
george lucas presents like it was like
the early warning signs
of what would happen to george lucas
uh thank you mr will guitar uh hope you
are well great to see you i saw the 78
incredible hulk again the other day
still blown away
did you ever see it have any thoughts
bixby spinal shiver is still amazing to
this day i only ever saw bits and pieces
of episodes of that
um so i don't really have that much of
an opinion on it i'm not sure i would be
one to
properly appreciate it 70s era
television
honestly most tv shows older than
the 90s often don't sit well with me
i love how we've this thing has like a
detective noir soundtrack and
there's just all these pictures of ducks
what's worse star chaser legend of
warren or star wars holiday special star
wars holiday
special is better because it's shorter
my little chickadee oh my god i'm
probably going to end up missing some
things that go on in the chat
maybe save captain america for the next
live stream it's time if time is short
look time's not the issue
i want to be distracted for as long as
humanly possible
the question is whether or not i feel
like i need to credit breeders of the
lost
weight breeders what do you mean breeder
what what
whoa
okay it sucks that chip zion is
remembered for voicing howard and not
playing baker in the original production
of into the woods
oh i didn't know that was him oh and
also thank you castile
can you impersonate napoleon dynamite
look i'll do whatever i want to do
god
so we have sexy voice is that just an
apple sitting on top of his tv
what's very weird to me right now is
like
they're hiding howard himself but
they're showing all this other duck
stuff and obviously the title is howard
the duck like do you think you're
building up to the reveal of how
and there he is and he looks like the
ducks we already saw pictures of
like but that was not worth hiding his
face over
do you do ab crunches i should but i
don't
shorts blaster
oh boy this
i i'll give him this for an 80s puppet
he's got decent expression mostly in the
eyes like the eyes are good
i can already tell that the mouth
movements on these because
all the beaks can do is open and close
like that's gonna be
uh iffy the uh the eyes are quite
expressive though i'm kind of impressed
you impersonate pennywise while doing
the smile
ah played
play duck wait a minute what was this
rated
what was it
and then and there's a naked duck and a
corset with nipples
the duck has nipples
i mean can we just start with the fact
that you know ducks don't nurse
their young because they're not mammals
uh
duck tits
yes i did i have seen that episode of
nostalgia credit back before i stopped
watching them
i'm oddly unsettled by the fact that we
only saw one black duck
it felt very token
so he's just randomly pulled through a
wormhole and the world is
the eggsh he comes from is shaped like
an egg because ducks
hi
okay wait a minute
wait a minute they're gonna do
big like philosophical
insightful sounding voice-over after
breeders of the lost whatever it was and
duck nipples
decide on a tone movie what the
oh boy okay somebody asked me to
pennywise so here's the thing about
doing an impression of pennywise because
pennywise's voice if you didn't realize
was just scooby-doo without the speech
impediment so
hey georgie why didn't you come down
here we all float down here
do you think we'll see howard and
she-hulk see how he lives in the
apartment below her in the comics
i would be very down for that the
question there is going to be budget
because it's going to require cgi
like i'm already wondering about the
budget of she-hulk because
i wonder about the cost of realizing her
in and of itself
but you know howard's been established
as cgi that's not a cheap effect and for
a tv show
i i don't know if they'll spring for it
i feel like he's the kind of thing that
introduced if she hulk gets a second
season
kind of like how um if just going by the
trailers they've clearly upped the
budget for the second season of the
mandalorian
oh 80s punks
the the weirdest truck
what the so they just thrust
a duck into a guy's face
what
what i
i'm gonna have trouble keeping up with
this
what is any of this
you filthy did you he's a talking
duck you go with filthy degenerate
what is this movie
wow
um you should impersonate pennywise and
do the
smile more often uh i do enjoy scare
housing people
someone accused me of that on um
uh in one of my comments earlier today
what are your thoughts on independence
day in 1996 i've been watching a long
time but you know what it was fun
that was a good popcorn movie it comes
to be a bad movie however the duck
hits the quack pot ian
you take a minute sit in the corner
think about what you just did
would you rather be watching the sign
shining right now no
no cause this is glorious insanity
cut the the hair the hair
on these characters
it's the greatest thing ever
forgot to mention that time lucifer is
another example of mental health
depiction done well one of the main
characters is a therapist
lucifer benefits from therapy huh
interesting
if you think this is nuts you haven't
seen the dario argento version of
phantom of the upper i've actually never
seen a dario argento movie
tied for worse picture at the razzies
with princes under the cherry moon i
don't
like the razzies are dumb can we agree
on that they're
they're very stupid
would rather be tied to a chair gagged
and forced to watch all six seasons of
glee or grease one and two well grease
one and two be over faster you're not
that's an easy call
how do you feel that the first marvel
movie ever has
duck tits in it uh a little weird
snot nose like what
thank you breathing nerddom and here
comes the quackfoot
let the female creature go i want that
on a t-shirt
hey vera hope you have a great stream
have you seen the shining tv show uh the
mini series no i have
not
[Laughter]
i've been doing too much toot
what it is
so pathetic when screenwriters very
clearly don't know what the street names
for drugs are
and so they just either make stuff up or
they pull the name that somebody told
them because they were messing with them
doing too much toot i assume two would
be cocaine because like
nose two whatever like screenwriters
should know
a good street word for cocaine they were
all on it in the 80s
oh
why do you hate dumb and dumber because
it's not funny
that's why
howard the duck is a pre-heart no doctor
why do you think there's so many
questions about tying you up and gagging
you
i'm assuming it's because you people are
finally on to me that's why i assume
that question keeps coming up
let's see you hate dumb and dumber
greece ferris bueller the shining
is there more oh
probably
but you know do you have to wait for it
to happen organically i don't
i don't keep a running list of hates i
don't like to hold on to that if i can
help it
cute was the only thing they could see
when they were high writing this
okay that i believe the bow in this
woman's hair
so much crimping went into this
mane
wow
you need to see tough guys don't dance
that movie is littered with
not real words and not real slang or
sayings i've
seen it three times still don't know
what happens oh dear
ever seen once bitten i have i have i
was like
13 and i saw it on tv i barely remember
it but i actually have
what is that
what is this song
what is this weird meat cute song
between a
girl with overly crimped hair and a
freaking
duck
do you think the ant howard animatronic
looks good or bad i think it looks good
for the time
like the failing of it is the bill
because all it can do is open and close
so like it can't get a lot of expression
in the mouth but i said earlier good
expression in the eyes surprisingly so
thoughts on coppola's bram stoker's
dracula i
like that movie it's a weird beast that
thing but i do like that movie
plus you know especially it's got uh
it's got keanu
trying to do british accent i know when
a
bastard sleeps in carfax abbey
it's the best kind of bad
get used to that thought vera the entire
movie you were still thinking it's a
duck
i managed to get a last minute haircut
before the new lockdown in england
see this this is one of the things
that's nice about my haircut i just need
a pair of clippers to
deal with this stuff if i
if and when i want to get it recolored
that i need a professional for
have you missed much no not really uh
charleston if you want to sync up with a
movie we're at
we're at 15 10 right now
beverly
what
she's he's not a cat why are you
offering milk out of a bowl
look even if you you're trying to wrap
your head around a
anthropomorphic duck why would you think
milk out of a bowl
oh boy songs of this of my thomas
still will be oh
that makes an odd kind of sense do you
consider yourself a diva
not really not in person anyway i
i can project diva when it suits me but
like not as a
not as a an actual standard mode of
being
would you rather watch this for batman
be superman well at least on a first
viewing this because at least this is
new pain uh
who's your favorite queen from six i
need to give it more listens
um
so i i can't answer that yet
so the duck has ptsd
from his dimension jumping i mean i i
guess
but again i'm coming back to pick
a tone movie
i would feed him duck because i'm evil
yes ben yes you are
an angry drunken review of the shining
you
someone would have to pay me i really
hate that movie
thomas dolby also wrote most of the
songs from fern gully oh dang
really
toxic love
and the and that now the the noir music
bag like i decided to educate myself on
the streets like you're a
duck you're a duck in suspenders and
she's a woman with hair
so crimped it's about to fall off her
scalp
what is this movie
doing what's worse
glee grease are great to show me
greatest showman is awesome
so don't even mention that in the same
breath
ah yeah
this had to been during lucas's toot
phase
i don't want to presume because i don't
know if it's a known factor that
he had any kind of issue like that
have you seen tales of arcadia netflix
shows i have not
found out on the 24th that i'm having a
nephew congratulations
okay so i gotta get back he's got a
cause
what is your deal beverly
at one point david bowie was gonna voice
howard really
i mean i can't imagine it would have
made that much of a difference i don't
think this
movie's gonna live or die on the voice
of howard
call me crazy
duck tour duck tour
who
i mean i can't complain i laughed a lot
at the
um gravity falls drug about ducktective
so i keep my mouth shut
his six months an anniversary depends
how old you are
if you're an adult no if you're in high
school yeah
sure
and so she's just flipping she's just
flipping through his
wallet i don't i don't like the look in
this woman's eyes it makes me
very uncomfortable
what why is it like sexy saxophone
music as she's looking at a one dollar
bill with a
duck on it what
why is this sexy saxophone music playing
when she finds a condom
[Music]
would you rather be watching hamilton on
disney plus right now i don't know i'm
kind of having fun
i won't want to watch this again i don't
think but for a one-off
with you people hey why not
bill cipher made this movie to mess with
your mind confirmed
yeah i swear scorpio shirt i need it
yeah like this has actually been part of
how i've been easing down during the day
i'm wearing a whole bunch of stuff
that was gifted to me by people who i
care about i've got
rings and i i had earrings on earlier i
had to take them off because of this but
my daughter gave me this shirt
i've got all kinds of stuff on that like
i'm just sort of pulling positive vibes
from
and uh it's been helping
which incarnation of the doctor would be
a duck
uh trout trotting would be a duck
i would say capaldi but he's a penguin
with his ass on fire
oh my cavity god my name fly screwed up
the timeline so bad his mother wants to
screw a duck
oh that is his mom isn't it oh god it's
tim robbins
with like what is this hair
and what was that reaction
what
what
it's like he's channeling a parody
of dr frankenstein what
what
i feel really bad for tim robbins
because
i'm pretty sure he thinks he knows what
kind of movie he's in
the problem is the movie doesn't know
what kind of movie it is so
none of this matches
uh according to imdb that's leia
thompson's real hair and she wish she
wore a wig for how much crimping they
put her hair through
i don't doubt that she probably had to
shave her head after this
what is wrong with this guy
what's your favorite breed of dog i
don't know i mean like i'm i'm partial
to bulldogs i grew up with a dachshund
there's a number i like
why do we have a creepy zoom in on tim
robin's crazy eyes
did you get any trick-or-treaters this
year no not at my house
uh this movie surprisingly fits into the
timeline where we've got the sports
almanac
why is he suddenly in a sweater
wait wait when did he get a hoodie
when did that happen
wouldn't it be so i wouldn't be
surprised if this was a hallucination
andy
dufresne had in solitary i think it
would better link up with
jacob's ladder
you should probably edit this into a
supercut of your most extreme reactions
what
what what
what is wrong with him
uh
thank you for catching that carowind
would you want a modern day reboot of
this movie part of the mcu
um like of this movie's plot
specifically
no
but i mean
i'm not sure howard holds his own movie
anyways but
have you ever heard of how image comedy
secretly stole howard from marvel from
under their nosers
oh you mean destroyer duck yes
i am i'm fully aware don't make it sound
like it's image
it was the guy who originally created
howard he was in on that
so it wasn't like the company of image
like did a dashboard
like no they facilitated him being a
jerk and implying that his new destroyer
dot character and image was actually
howard and the one at marvel was a clone
so like that was him gerber i think was
the guy's name
passed away unfortunately
she's really deeply hurt that a duck
is annoyed with her
why is she saying these lines so
bizarrely
sultry
god those leggings why ha ha
why are you this emotionally invested in
him woman
oh did you dress up for halloween no i
did not
a that's a new plot point
he needs a job
what is this an employment office worker
and so wait he
his disguise is a pair of sunglasses
and she's just she's just gonna she's
gonna jab her finger into the chest
of a duck
will this movie decide if people are
weirded out by the giant duck or not
cause last seen we just had a guy be all
like
which would be appropriate and here
she's acting like
she's seen this every other day is that
meant to be the joke
is this supposed to be funny is this a
comedy
i don't know it can't decide on its tone
why is he staring at her
ass
what
what
was he going to bite this
woman's ass why
what is going
on
so what is the bar asana why is this guy
sweating
he can't oh how funny
he's a duck who can't swim
wha huh
my brain
is breaking
why have we devoted
what five six minutes to a subplot
of howard getting a job and then
quitting
after gratuitous dna human this time
upgrade maybe i don't know and now he
just he quits
so like that was a complete plot
cul-de-sac had no purpose
the only kind of movie you'd do that in
would be a comedy if the boys to make
people laugh more than i actually tell a
story and have a plot
but this thing kid doesn't seem to know
that whether or not it's a comedy
because it's treating other stuff
dead freaking serious
make up your mind and now we're back to
people
freaking out
make up your
mind movie are people
freaked out by him or are they not
do they not care pick
one
why does he have fingernails oh thanks
rowan that's one more thing to add to
the pile
do you need a hug i don't know what i
need
i
and now it's getting weirdly somber
again
like
what is the tone
of this movie
somebody tell me
wait isn't that the same freaking club
he was trying to in the first place
so now the plot has literally done a
full circle
and we could have just jumped here we
could have started here
you gotta skip to the last i don't know
however long of
i'm not that drunk i'm just
i'm
you need something strong maybe those
laughing pills
i'd like my life is jokerish enough
already as it is
the tone adult it's not though did you
see tim robbins
with his freaking saturday morning
cartoon character
no so no that doesn't work as an overall
tone
oh but if he didn't got the job then
there wouldn't be wacky shenanigans for
the trailer
oh joy
and now we're what good so wait now
suddenly he's
jealous that some guy is cat calling
beverly
you like you made no indication that you
even liked her vaguely
platonically
you need whatever tim robbins was on
yeah that looked like good stuff
leia's not a bad singer to be fair like
that's not my concern
did the sexual content seriously catch
you off guard
not entirely like i know that it gets
implied later that they like
that they do it but like i didn't expect
it to be this pervasive
across the film
and now we're back to treating the duck
as like oh
it's a duck no big deal
are those jokes are those supposed to be
jokes
i don't know and i don't think the movie
does either
ah you're gonna need a good strong beer
i hate
beer don't recommend me beer
um do you want a pet
i don't my daughter has a hamster
why is the bartender f like a parody of
a frenchman
are you sure you don't want to take up
drinking
what was your best and we're subject to
school i was actually very even keeled
like on when i took
when i took the uh the sats they got the
exact same score on the
um on the literacy and the math
portions
maybe you deserve a good movie rather
than a double bat a palette cleanser
i don't know
the hair so much crimping
these women had their hair destroyed
by this movie
and now i've got hiccups great
ah
do you not like la la land i actually
like la la land pretty well the ending
makes the movie
and again we're back to nonchalant about
a walking talking duck
[Music]
you need to be as drunk as tony stark
and iron man 2 to handle this movie i
don't need to be fighting my friends
welcome to howard the duck circle of
life where you finish
going around a circle you must go to
square one and go around again this is
basically this
movie's plot why does this exist i don't
know
why don't you like moulin rouge because
the movie needs to be put on ritalin
and i'm allowed to say that because i
have add and i was on ritalin at one
point
that move i had it took me five times
trying to watch the movie to get past
the first 20 minutes because it gave me
a goddamn headache
and ewan mcgregor's character is an
[ __ ]
aztecs came from mars
circular italian food object
it's like every other character that
gets introduced
is from a completely different movie
from the other characters
nothing matches nothing links up
none of this fits together
just got here a few minutes ago what are
you drinking at the moment i am drinking
a down east pumpkin blend hard cider
down east is good stuff i recommend them
assuming you are 21 years of age or
older
what is going on
oh
nothing else this movie is eclectic
that's a movie for it
who's worst christian uh from moulin
rouge or
ferris bueller ferris bueller's a worse
person
if only because i feel like christian
will eventually have a moment of
realization when he
recognizes what a do she was ferris
never will
he's incapable of it
it's been weird since this movie started
am i right well you're not wrong
why did you pick this one i picked this
one because it's my
intention to do a list a ranked list
of all the marvel adaptations that
aren't spider-man x-men or the mcu
so things like this blade daredevil
etc and i only had two movies left that
fit that category that i hadn't seen yet
well three until yesterday yesterday i
watched punisher in 1989.
today i watch this and then if i'm up to
it i watch
1990s captain america if i'm not up to
it i watch that in the morning
this or last christmas um
i don't know because last christmas was
merely boring
up until it went bat [ __ ] this is bat
[ __ ] front to back i don't know
you know ferris bueller's principal is
in this right i am
and that is going to make me slightly
uncomfortable viewing
but i'll manage
jody webecker
as the 13th doctor what the hell
what
why are you flashing your ass at him
uh
what are you doing this should be as
weird to you
as it should be to her howard
what the hell
she is a shaved ape to you
what are you doing
what is
happening
and his feathers goes up and he goes
whoops
as if it's a premature ejaculation
[Music]
how
why is she so aggressive
just kidding screw you
no don't screw you like no like stop
stop all of this
oh oh thank god
oh thank god other people showed up
yes thank you
oh
ypg this is 15 rated
should be well i mean like they don't
update american movie ratings
at the time it came out pg-13 didn't
exist
so it was either p e g or r
you thought how it was gross now the
convinced sex offender shows up
yeah forgive me for not drawing a ton of
attention to that because like i'm not
in the mood to process it but yes i'm
aware
with that
mr time last time lashes shorter
if you ever get time travel you need to
go back to the set of this movie with a
clock yeah
it's time to stop
wasn't temple of doom one of the movies
that made the pg-13
rating uh yeah that and uh the first
gremlins
were like the ones that kind of kicked
that off what are your thoughts on lorax
2012
insulting
who would win the living flesh computer
the living flash supercomputer bill
cipher
that's actually legitimately a good
question because the living flesh
supercomputer has its tendrils into a
lot more it
it has the ground floor it has the home
team advantage because
it has been slowly taking over
everything
in all forms of existence so
it has a stronger foundation whereas
bill cipher while he would be coming in
with the initial disadvantage
might be capable of enough raw chaos to
throw it off its game
it will be an interesting matchup to be
sure
is that the answer you were expecting
seth green and james gunn probably watch
this every time they film the guardians
of the galaxy movie
to know what not to do with howard
uh what are your thoughts on the 2018
grinch movie it was
boring
the cover of science digest people have
been seeing this duck walking around and
haven't given a crap
i'm going to assume science i just won't
either
if you could remove one movie from your
memory what would
would it be this one no
no there aren't many movies that i
legitimately want my time back
i'm trying to think if there are any
like
as a person who fancies themselves a
creative
there's benefit in seeing what not to do
why do you like ocean's eight because
the ladies vibe real good together
that's why
and that's the point of the oceans
movies
the entire purpose of those movies the
reasons any of them work
is it's just a bunch of great actors
vibing together
and ocean's 8 has that so what the
hell's the problem
this is still better than catwoman
i don't know if it is it's
bad in more interesting ways than
catwoman is
i'll give you that because catwoman is
bad and a very
predictable it's bad in exactly the way
in which you would expect it to be bad
this then
how
wait why are we doing it on the on the
waterfront parody now
i i don't understand
what this is oh
thoughts on ocean's eleven it's uh it's
a jam
session of a movie it's fun
do you think marvel studios would give
howard another shot at a as a movie
eventually
uh no they'll put him as a supporting
player and other stuff
thoughts on x-men's origins please tell
me you hate it
it pisses me off that it's the only time
left schreiber got to play sabretooth
because he is
awesome as sabretooth he's so good but
yeah the movie's not good
they were going to make a tv show about
your life who would you want to play you
i would play myself because i am a
narcissistic egomaniac
thank you very much
that's not officially diagnosed that's
that's me self-assessing
i really want howard the duck to become
a thanos level villain
what the hell
and now suddenly we're in a science
gone mad story with burn makeup on a
random
dude like what
there's still an hour to go no no
this is the climax isn't it no
we're only 50 minutes in to an hour and
50 minute move
how how
how is there an hour left in this movie
how
something this bad has no right being
this long
let's sing something from hamilton i
can't if i sing the
live stream gets flagged and then the
live chat doesn't get archived
time grinds when you're suffering sort
of like
50 minutes past i guess kind of tracks
it's just
plot structure how is there an hour left
i don't understand i don't understand
what in european is the best version of
the dark phoenix saga
the comic the dark phoenix saga
if you're actually if you're asking me
what's the best adaptation
probably the 90s cartoon but that wasn't
very good either so
none of them they're all bad to varying
degrees
see that detective had the most
realistic reaction
which was just to laugh at the absurdity
of what he was looking at
i do believe we made it to the point
where i just got her panties so twisted
that she got a 1g of doom
i'll i'll i'll thank you not to
speculate about my panties thank you
very much
very presumptive of you to assume i'm
wearing any
why why was he stripped down to boxers
so help me god if we see his corkscrew
i'm done
i'm done
they crammed two movies into one theory
they crammed two movies in one because
they knew they weren't getting his
sequel
i i'll buy that
what is
thanos didn't want to wipe out humanity
because they ruined his plan he wanted
to wipe out humanity because
we made this movie that he'd be within
his rights to do it
who's the best character in this movie
so far
you're asking me to pick a favorite
turd out of a cat's litter box
i don't know
i said beep beep i'm a sheep i said beep
beep i'm a sheep i don't know why that
came up
there's no corkscrew in this movie oh
thank god
like legitimately uh elf spy network
thank you for that reassurance because i
wasn't prepared to take anything for
granted at this point
star wars holiday special is so bad
george lucas hated it
again if i was watching the star wars
holiday special
it would be over by now
why do i get the feeling howard is the
perverted cousin scrooge mcduck stop
talking about
i'd buy that
howard the talk was the midnight entity
howard the duck is the timeless child we
must accept it
hmm
huh
thank you charleston i'm glad you
appreciated that
i love you herself thank you it's
getting quite like it's like getting
long enough that i have to tie it back
when i eat now unless they get hair in
my mouth
and he drives a wood panel station wagon
unrelated but is ms wayne acceptable i'd
rather you didn't because that's
that's that's what my um daughter's
mother goes by so that would throw me
off
badly
are they really trying to raise tension
for a random
it's not even a car chase for just
driving a car halfway through the movie
oh screw you
screw you
for your needless [ __ ] sex change
joke bite me howard
would you rather be watching star chaser
right now i don't know i don't know if
this is notably better than the
anal violation of the fembot
if howard was the same as the woman does
that make him a witch
howard and leia thompson are ray's
parents
makes more sense than palpatine
oh
what happened i can't see it i ca what
happened
black cover was that the
professor has clearly been taken over by
something and he's like
i'm transforming from the inside it's a
thing yeah weird stupid creepy voice
and howard goes oh great like a sex
change
i'm not flipping off anybody watching
i'm flipping off the movie
do we need to retroactively pay you to
watch this travesty i'd appreciate it
i'm not gonna say you have to but like
it would alleviate the pain there's no
anesthetic like money
hmm
ah
i've got 50 minutes left to go my
drink's done
this movie is so bad that showing it to
somebody is considered a war crime by
the sun tolerance
hey
as i mentioned last stream leia
thompson's daughter zoe deutsch from
zombieland 2. oh that's right you didn't
mention that
remember when i watched ghostbusters
when i ditched ghostbusters to watch
fanforstick with you
i don't know why you did but bless you
let me guess the restaurant is serving
duck
well they've all got japanese headbands
so i'm going to assume
as much they may have already said
i don't know i don't know
according to the producer lucas
continued support to the film after his
failure because he felt
it would later be seen in a better light
than at the time of its release
sorry george
nope
howard couldn't pay his bill
i'm sorry what
he was taken over by the dark
overlord of the universe
where did this nonsense come from
i mean obviously for want of a villain
but like it's not even like this is
something that connects to howard's home
world so like
a completely random other alien force
aside from howard was also brought down
and now is the villain
did i make you laugh i don't know i
can't keep track of anything anymore
you're defecable
what the hell
and so now the dark overlord's gonna
what destroy condiments
for no flipping reason
yeah screw you mustard
up yours ketchup what the
hell
why are you telling them your plan
i'm um
i'm drawing a blank at this point
and so now we have random redneck
jag-offs
yes the quack foo is very impressive as
he kicks someone in the stomach and goes
doink
to their head
did he just call that guy a cracker
that guy just ran into a pie
howard didn't even throw a pie at him
the guy just ran into a pie that he was
holding
i refuse to believe that this takes
place on earth
if howard came from some other dimension
some other planet
this is not earth this is something else
there's no
flipping way this is
the world in which we exist or is meant
to even vaguely represent it
this is madness
yes it is
lady have you not caught on to the fact
that he is possessed but
so now they're just gonna they're just
gonna kill
and this is not earth i
this is the bad place yes this is the
bad place
he's not wrong you hardly know him lady
what
[Music]
what is this restaurant
the entire aesthetic including the
outfit of the wait staff
is 50s diner complete with cream pies
yet they have japanese flag headbands
and the chef is clearly meant to be from
japan
as he's prepared to just lop the head
off a duck i suppose that's supposed to
be justification
japanophobia it was big in the 80s
like what but
it's not even just howard what is any of
this
cajun sushi this makes about as much
sense
and so now me cleaver is just flying
around
because why the hell not
and it's gonna uh yeah i knew there was
gonna be a big emphasis on
oh it might have chopped his corkscrew
off
so wait a guy just used his mind
to send a meat cleaver flying around and
your
solution is to run up to him and go
that's it buddy you're out of here
like what
you're quacking me up
catch me up what happened the last few
minutes i don't know i don't know
they went to a restaurant and jeffrey
jones is
is possessed by an evil alien and
the restaurant owners decided they were
going to cook howard in the restaurant
aesthetic is 50s diner and
and japanese steakhouse
i don't i don't know
what
he's too short for that walk this way
joke
that doesn't work but
none of this works even the basic jokes
don't work
help
send help
what do you mean what if you don't he's
he's flying you around with his mind why
doesn't he just
take it you're really telling me that
this freaking duck has too strong a grip
on this thing for you to just take it
and i'm sorry i'm talking to this place
it's not intimidating
if it's meant to be it just doesn't work
sending all our love and support i need
it
we only just passed with the one hour or
ten rowan stop telling me how much time
is left
you're not helping
we can't help you it's too late for you
it's true
disney sent help by taking it out of
george lucas's hands
uh
any more duck puns you want me to make
please don't
please
what's your eyes just for the ambulance
i'm not telling you my address
uh i'm not sure it's an emergency like
maybe just call the humane society
amnesty international something
just sounds like jeffrey jones smoked 50
cigarettes and got a sore throat
yeah it doesn't it doesn't it
i am the dark overlord of the universe
you can tell
because of the way my throat needs a
lozenge
[Music]
please live stream duck hunt after this
i've got an original nintendo and light
gun and duck hunt up in the attic i'm
not hooking them up though
it would be cathartic or at the very
least would redirect my anger to that
damn
dog
just be thankful it wasn't tim robbins
being possessed
uh yeah i guess
what the hell and now
we have body horror
tentacles coming out of his mouth
mm-hmm it's doing bad from harvey
fierstein impression
i used to be able to do harvey fierstein
and i am yao king of the rock
olda you mean like shelly winters older
she'll be clean older
where's my baseball where's my baseball
cap
what movie are you in tim robbins
because it's not the same movie that
everyone else is in
light is a feather oh god you're hurting
me
just be thankful it wasn't leia thompson
getting possessed tentacles coming out
of lorraine michael
is way too disturbing to imagine oh
thanks for that
that tongue cigarette lighter part was
cut from the old uk dvd
rightfully so
you kind of sound like hamill's joker i
can do hamill's joker
uh well batman
isn't it lovely that you joined us today
do make yourself comfortable
neither shoulder yes yes carowind
i'm gonna need a shoulder and a drink
and like a hug and many many many
reassurances that
it was uh that it's all gonna be okay
nine out of ten laugh was a bit off i i
didn't transition into the laugh quite
right so yeah
that's fair
vodka or jack daniels jack daniels i
don't really like vodka
that might be partly because vodka was
what i started drinking when i first got
to college and so like that's what i
had my experience of drinking too much
on
stuff tastes like gasoline
i really want to know what was going
through george's head when he made this
i
i would be afraid to find out
or any of the other actors in the same
movie as each other i'm not sure they
are
um
i don't know somebody imdb it
thoughts on mrs doubtfire i have not
rewatched it in a long time
uh i haven't rewatched it since
and you know it's a well-meaning movie
but it does fit the pattern of
um a man would only ever put a dress on
because circumstance forced it
so knowing it's part of that trope and
that depiction
of men presenting feminine uh
i don't like it's well-meaning enough
i'd probably still be okay with it but i
haven't rewatched it in a long time
your daughter's gonna have to tuck you
in tonight she's with her mother tonight
that's that's what the live stream is
every other week i don't live stream
on nights where on weeks where i have
her have you watched the boys
no but i don't want to i don't like
garth
ennis he is 70 as clever as he thinks he
is
and now this is gonna be a big weird
triumphant kind of moment because
normally ducks can fly but howard can't
fly but now he's
flying a thing so this duck flies
do you want me to duck you into bed
why so serious okay well see now you're
asking me to do a different joker
my father was a drunk
and a monster
and one time my mother
pushed him too far and he put
the knife in her mouth and he said why
so serious
probably got the lines wrong but you get
it here's what i think of this movie
stick to what you're good at this is not
what you're good at star wars is what
you're good at
like this is not what any of these
people like nobody's coming off well in
that none of the actors
not the direction not the script like
everyone is guilty i know everyone likes
to blame george lucas
but like everyone is responsible for
this
we're suddenly in a roger moore bond
film yeah a bit
beer i'm sure someone will be able to
detect you and i'm sure they will
might have already asked this did lynn
mention what's did liz mention what
series of supernatural she's up to by
the way i believe she's on this
she's either on the second to last one
or like
the one before that she's she's burned
through it pretty well
can you impersonate tim curry's
pennywise i don't know because i i've
only seen bits and pieces of that movie
so i don't know if i
if i know it well enough um
to really be able to pull that one
say you're just
oh god's sake
and leia thompson has been getting
snobby to michael j fox the year
prior i mean
nobody knows what turns their own career
is gonna take
i feel like a young kevin feige was
watching this movie and was thinking
okay somebody needs to fix this
uh sometimes we all need to stand and
beat up
you're despicable
there you can stop now
uh have you seen his dark materials i
did the first few episodes of the
series version i didn't love it
uh
you could always do frank and further
oh rocky
i don't think i have as much resonance
even even like when i um
even when i drop it down to my lower
register i don't quite have the
uh the reverberation
that tim curry has
they're still
aside from the fact that a bunch of
these scenes were completely pointless
and shouldn't exist at all
so many of the scenes that are in here
are like minimum
twice as long as they should be why are
they still in this damn
plane
will you be watching captain america
after this i'm gonna break for the
bathroom
to get more something but
uh yeah i think i still will be thank
thank you peter so you can pay the bill
for the film
because you super shout out i'll let
that slide but
um
now see that i needed to hear miss
wicketwolf i appreciate that
jesse eisenberg likes luther was a
better villain than the dark lord of the
universe
i don't know if i go there
this or the room i haven't seen the room
i know it my reputation i might as well
have seen it at this point i've seen so
much stuff about it but
i haven't seen it
oh
i hope you can make it through the scott
awful film and i and as someone
on gmt half past one in the morning i
bid you good night i love the scorpio
team thank you jamie thank you for
joining me
my kid got me this i love it
very ghostbustery these uh
effects on the dark overlord of the
universe
what would you rather be doing at this
moment
honestly as
much as this is what this is
i'm happy to be here because like as the
title of the stream says this is a
distraction
this is a reason for me to not stare at
election results i would
rather be here i am where i want to be
with the people i want to be with
thank you
oh dear god
i thought you did a review of the room
no i did a review of
room the brie larson movie but not
the room the uh tommy wiseau movie
when they were making this film i think
they were winging it
oh i quite like that he seems to be
looking worse each time we see him
i mean like it's decent enough and the
like the progression is fine
it's a decent they're still in the
freaking flying thing
how long are they gonna draw this out
we get the point they're flying to get
there we assume they'll get there why
are we on scene
three of them flying this flipping thing
[Music]
how did we know that no one would work
we had a spy
we had a spy on the inside that's right
hercules mulligan
of course like the big line for me for
him
with that
i'm hercules mulligan i need no
introduction you knock me down i get the
[ __ ] back up again
and apparently i knock off my headphones
when i do it
jesus
oh
let's see
uh i'm showing a bad movie to my friends
tomorrow called mano's hands of fate
i've heard bad things about that that
like that's considered among the
worst films ever made that one
this movie ducks oh goodness
i'm guessing 24 hour marathon of this
movie is jeffrey jones's punishment in
princeton
that's that works they need more trailer
fodder not three
scenes worth they don't
trailers are three minutes tops
he's a duck terrorist am i supposed to
like tim robbins in this movie
cuz don't
like beverly's a freak but at least
seems to mean well
how was the universe's wave telling you
to stop watching this movie
[Music]
do you watch my hero academia no
um i think he's comic relief
i mean i guess in theory
but
none of the comic moments in this
are relieving
except for the fact that i feel like i
want to relieve myself on this movie
that was crude even for me i say even
for me i'm not usually crude
i'm breaking you are watching the
breaking of a human being
wondering why we're now in like the
seventh minute of this friggin
plane
oh how many times have you seen hamilton
on disney plus
three times what i've listened to the
soundtrack quite a bit more
oh when this finally hits disney plus
the entire service will explode and
kevin feige will return to heaven having
failed his mission to save comic book
films
maybe they just originally wanted to
make duck porn but were forced
into making a movie by some cruel force
is it like the um
the justification for the old nudie
films they had to pretend they were
either nature documentaries or
fake a plot even though that wasn't the
reason anyone came
uh to keep your headphones on you could
use some duct tape
don't joke about that i live in vermont
we use duct tape for
everything if you can't duck it
[ __ ] it not literally
maybe they just originally oh no i said
that i read that one
i just saw that john barry did the score
oh how the mighty fall like
everyone involved in this this has got
to be a low point
for everyone
you're only human yeah true
pain voice i will break you uh see you
say that but i've been on tick tock
where there's a sound
working its way around which is uh which
isn't the main voice it's markiplier
let me see hold on let me see if i can
get this
i will break you only when you deserve
to be broken
i can't go as deep as markiplier does
but yeah
it's uh that's a good sound
ramsey bolt in the movie theon greyjoy
you
why are we looking at her bra why is she
half undressed
why
silence is gold and duct tape is silver
very true
do you play guitar hero i did for a
little while back in the day guitar hero
2 specifically
i never kept up with it after that have
you seen zootopia i have there's a
review on this channel i
like it a lot it's a good movie
i'm sorry i haven't been paying
attention to the movie i don't know why
he has beverly on a
thing and is raising her towards a very
phallic device
i don't know i'm pretty sure i don't
want to know
hey markiplier is such a good voice
oh he really does that guy's got an
epic voice
how to survive this movie duck and cover
oh
do you play just dance no i've never
played any of the dance games like that
or dance dance revolution or
any of that
why is a big ass laser mounted on a
what is this thing a trolley what
would this movie be better or worse if
catwolf made a cameo
i mean that would suit everything else
going on you might as well
so basically a poultry version of the
shape of water
don't insult the shape of water that's a
great movie
by cover i mean cover the screen so you
don't have to see this
are you wearing sock
am i wearing socks yes
it's november in vermont i'm wearing
socks
i'm wearing thick socks and slippers
nicely insulated silvers because
it's cold up here
many you love this film you're a quack
addict oh my god
why do you do this to me
freud would have a field date with this
film
uh but i don't put too much talk in his
work he was a quack ah
anytime you listen to fat bottom girl
anytime i listen to fat bottom girls i
think of you oh really
thank you that's a good song to be
associated with
oh
why is there a little friggin dune buggy
thing that's perfectly sized for a
duck that's this tall why do they have
that
[Music]
um
great bad one-liners
that'll save the movie we do this to you
because we love to see you suffer but we
do it out of love
huh this is a poultry attempt at a comic
book movie
how was there more than five minutes
left in this
freaking movie
um
for children yeah
duck boobs and beverly hitting on howard
you know for kids
promise me we'll have some duck for
dinner sometime soon and call it howard
if i ate duck i would i don't care for
duck it's all dark meat on duck
it's a gun why does he have to get
closer
to whatever
do you like twizzlers yes i do
i got a duck out but this was a great
time
really excited to see your rank on the
old marvel movies
don't quote the critic he's a hack
i don't begrudge the man his work i
begrudge the man his business his
business ethics that's why i stopped
watching
you don't like dark meat vera
um assuming you that
as you indicate you're asking that in a
completely non-innuendo fashion no i
don't like dark meat
do you hear about the macy's
thanksgiving day parade this year i did
not
why are you still asking why when it
comes to this movie why went out the
window with duck nipples yeah
that's that's actually true this movie
displayed its intentions of making zero
sense of any kind very early on
no harm no foul oh god
ow
gotta get some sleep at the end of this
movie but i'd rather
but i'm rather pawned of this livestream
okay that one was a reach
oh jeez i'm kicking my thing
um
so now they're gonna fight the thing
what is this movie doing
[Music]
you should do more live reaction
streaming we love watching you because
we're all birds of a feather
i'm not gonna make this the regular
thing but like it'll probably happen
again in the future
oh what's your favorite halloween candy
that's an odd question because like the
only candy that i ever think of as being
halloween specific is candy corn which i
actually like more than a lot of people
everyone in this movie is useless
ew ew
it is the thing what is what the hell
next live stream you should watch the
shining i will not watch the shiny again
unless somebody pays me
finally managed to watch red dwarf
promised land i found it enjoyable but
some part of the series was your opinion
on it
um i have a review up in the break room
of geeks so you can find it there
i cannot um form coherent thoughts or
memories to recollect
uh my notions on it i remember being
more or less positive on it not
exceptionally positive but positive
enough
okay hold on i gotta
i gotta look a word up here
um
uh
uh let's see
there we go yannick
that's the word i was looking for the uh
the mouth of this creature is very
yannick
howard the duck is all wet he's
completely useless now
it's the same year as the fly aliens in
little shop of horrors
oh boy that puts it in horrifying
perspective
you should watch some shoe right after
this uh
i might fall asleep to that i guess
you're an expert on this film now
ah so
ultimately the big clever solution was
just to
shoot it with the gun he already had
what a hero
you gotta admit this is a poultry excuse
for a movie a real turkey completely
quackers now i'd probably be tarred and
feathered you should be
[Music]
how about the black cauldron or moulin
rouge i don't know i haven't re-watched
black cauldron in a while probably give
that another shot
stephen king also hates the shining yes
but he hates it just because it deviated
from his book
i hate it because i don't think it's a
good movie so
my minority opinion is in the minority
of minority opinions
i'm half expecting stan lee to walk and
take one look at what's happening and go
f
this yeah
what the hell
whoa something blew up
how exciting and now there's probably
going to be a whole oh no
did howard die thing
but he won't because
there is no justice
what about the witches what the new one
or the uh previous movie because the
previous one i've seen
once when i was a kid new one i haven't
[Music]
seen
here we go this whole big oh he's dead
no
he's not
i agree with you on the shiny my 13 year
old nephew
insisted on watching it last christmas
eve because he heard about it
what are your thoughts on the craft 1996
have not rewatched it since the 90s i
remember enjoying it
what is for rooza balk doing these days
i wonder that sometimes
so what would have been really funny is
he just sat up doing the whole i'm not
howard anymore as if he was possessed by
a dark lord of the universe
you know what would have been the best
thing if they had shot him
immediately and his stupid dumb
joke and that was the end of the movie
stop
making kissy faces at each other
ew
she had a wordless cameo in the new
craft film oh
hoped it would have been more than that
yes because people at a concert would
really be
rocking out to a song about howard the
duck
like i could vaguely buy
the the ninja wrap thing in the second
ninja turtles because i
bet everybody in that club was on
ecstasy
she's in a tv show called paradise city
oh okay
can you spell
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
no
this is the saturday morning cartoon
theme was there a saturday morning
cartoon
was that a thing i don't know i've lost
all grip on reality
so this movie is effectively a furry
marvel fans fever dream put to screen
no no i would expect better out of the
fever dream of a
furry marvel fan
drake is a very popular artist oh
what are your thoughts on saving mr
banks it was pretty good
more even-handed than i expected
although it did ultimately
favor disney probably more than reality
would have but whatever
duckwork yes of course he does a duck
walk
while playing them what is he yeah it is
a guitar i thought for a second it was a
keytar that would have made that would
have been more perfectly 80s
oh but he's going to play this through
the credits so i have to
keep watching even though the credits
are rolling
ah why doesn't this movie ever
[Applause]
end
oh thoughts on the mary poppins returns
i haven't seen it
oh
is it over is
is it over howard get off the stage
is it over
why isn't it over
oh oh thank god
oh thank god okay
okay
i um
they stay santa quiet now you can still
hear anything but moaning the heart the
duck is not
yet over oh god
what do you think of the jeffrey jones
thinking is turning to the cigarette
lighter very hentai
that bit am i okay no
no okay um
i think there was no be quote oh god
please stop
okay uh i'm not gonna stop the live
stream i'm gonna keep it going
uh i'm gonna use the bathroom
get myself more
anesthesia and i'll be back in a minute
take five uh i'll i'll be back
i should i should have gotten like a
sign back in five
so anybody in the chat can say back in
5.
we're going to power through we're going
to do the captain america movie
yeah yeah we're going to do that
after these messages we'll be right back
uh
uh
oh
and somehow
the credits are still going
uh
i've not seen this captain america movie
is it crap well
in america it went direct to uh video
i'm still covering it um for inclusion
on my list of
non-mcu marvel movies because it did get
theatrical release
in europe so
it's supposedly not very good
a lot of people worked really hard on
this film when they ask all they ask is
for you to remember their names
i'm pretty sure they want me to forget
their names on this particular case
okay
when watching these things do you
consider that you are your own worst
enemy or however the duck is
i prefer to project outward and blame
howard
uh have you seen the scout's guide to
the zombie apocalypse nope
i remember a trailer that's about it
uh
okay it's 1 55 in the uk right now i
really need to go to sleep
someone tell howard duck uh someone god
oh god i can't even like it's projecting
itself
somebody tell counselor geeks i am gone
okay
the song might be ending but the duck
not over uh
so the captain america movie that i'm
going to be watching
which you can find on youtube
so this is very easy to sync up with me
if you look up captain
america 1990
you will find it
one hour 37 minutes which means it's
shorter
uh the full movies on youtube for free
uh
i love it when you say my cavity yeah a
lot of people do
let me see here ready to trade off for a
couple
uh yeah yeah
okay so i'm gonna give it
uh two three minutes
for anyone who wants to pull this thing
up
and uh and yeah
then uh then we'll do this
uh do you need an extra five minutes it
won't help
the pain is real
okay so there's that and that
no bring that bike down there we go
brb yep no rush carolyn i'll wait for
you
can't do it election updates keep
dropping i'm the the whole point of this
is to avoid election updates do not talk
about the election
i'll let it pass that you were just
saying that updates are dropping because
that's what happens
but like seriously i'll put you in time
out for it
the the point of this stream
is to not uh
focus on the election
have you ever sang to anyone before i'm
well yeah i've done musical theater so
yeah
howard the talk oh
i'm not gonna kill you i'm just gonna
hurt you
really really
bad everyone's favorite joker
florida joker
uh remember what kills you makes you
stronger are you
you're sure i've got that right sounds
about right
i have head cannons that make howard the
duck of the mcu
the same being as from lucas's movie
well i mean he's jumping dimensions in
this movie that's easy enough to head
canon
why don't you like the nickname daddy
cut
forget the language i'm about to use
because it's not my [ __ ] name
that's why same reason i don't like any
nickname
it's not my goddamn name
that's why that should be reason
enough
uh will you be sticking around after the
captain america i don't know we'll see
if i'm still
conscious i've searched for the movie
but i ain't watching it
uh it will just distract me from
watching you ah fair enough
who's your favorite joker um
probably mark hamill but because i
didn't really like the killing joke and
i mixed families about the
um arkham asylum games i'm gonna have to
narrow that down to
mark hamill's joker from the animated
series
which would include mask of the phantasm
and
uh return of the joker hang on a second
um
okay
lined up the movie fix myself a coffee
with caramel i would recommend irishing
up that coffee a bit
loved your video about the nickname
thing thank you
i like i played it for comedy but it's
accurate
you're being disturbed by the kid having
your name and the woman in black is the
same how i feel about the dopey villainy
ghostbusters 2016 having my name
oh god what a lame villain he was too
why mixed feelings on the arkham games i
thought they had the best joker though
he was overused
i it's just that like here's the thing
there's nothing wrong with the arkham
games but i'm just
very over
batman being that dark i'm just kind of
i'm just kind of done with it if i'm
being completely honest
uh fun fact mark hamill technically
played a live action joker and the pilot
episode of birds of prey
however he was still just the voice
while another actor was the physical
presence weirdly
yeah i know about that
all right we're gonna get this show on
the road in a few minutes
what are you thoughts i'm recommending
for a dream i only ever watched it once
because it's horrifying
which it should be like i classify that
as a horror movie
straight up
okay i did switch from my ipad to my
phone because the battery in my ipad was
at 25
uh okay
here we go
pull this thing up captain america
1990 starting in
three two one
ago
21st century film corporation a
production company i've literally never
heard of
that's a promising start
someplace in italy someplace that i
probably wouldn't mispronounce so i'm
not going to try
matt salinger yeah that's right
this movie stars the son of the guy who
wrote um
catcher in the rye
that book sucks
just to put that on the record
this was the one the guy from canon film
set up after they collapsed
oh oh no
did you ever watch a movie tv show as a
kid but when you re-watch it as an adult
you're like oh god this is crap i
actually like this as a kid
um probably but i don't have a go-to
example
enter the fascists
honestly
solid opening so far
i mean it's not amazing or anything but
like
so far it's competent
which is a you know
let's change your pace
fortress lorenzo okay
for me it was dora and barney i was such
a stupid kid i blame my parents for
allowing me to watch them
i don't know stuff aimed at kids that
young i feel like that's almost unfair
to
to re-watch those with adult eyes
you know
although barney
so they have a large
red naked rat
uh foreign
i may not have as much to say because uh
so far at least it's competent
there's a really good documentary on
canon films called what else electric
boogaloo
i used to love sharkboy lava girl when i
was younger as shameful as that sounds
that's rough
so their brilliant plan
is to take a child of high intelligence
and subjective to a to an experiment
that might kill him
good use of resources
like if the whole thing is that it
potentially doubles his intelligence
then
why did they even need someone of high
intelligence that seems like a waste of
a smart
person who could be helping you like get
confirm that it works on something other
than a rat
get somebody dumb and make them smart
never mind i just told you the plot one
of the plot points of the super mario
brothers movie
[Music]
don't listen to me clearly
1943
oh so we're just jumping to the fact
that steve rogers is already the
volunteer for the super soldier serum
just sleep straight to that don't find
out anything about who he is
get a sense of him as a person is just
like nope he's
he's a hero as designated by
narrative decree do you play mario kart
not anymore
i did back in the day
they did experiments on ducks as well
and created a super intelligent duck
thought we were escaping politics
tonight
i mean
is queen the only classic rock band you
like i like
um i like the rolling stones i like some
of the beatles
are you a trans woman no no i'm not i am
gender fluid
i am not a trans woman
he's kind of a weird looking dude
his chin and his forehead jut out at
about the same distance
i miss your hat it's hanging up right
over there
i can see it from where i'm sitting
uh that's cute it's trying to be a real
movie
would you ever get a dog the main reason
the main thing that keeps me from
getting a dog
is that it ties me down to the house
and most of my social life well
you know when it was permissible to have
a social life
um you know i spend on day trips out to
other parts of the state
and when i go and see liz you know i
usually stay over with her
that's in another town so i spend
enough time away from the house that
having to be here to take care of a dog
or having to board a dog
on a semi-regular basis neither of which
is particularly appealing to me
wow that is the matte paintingist matte
painting that ever matt painted
i don't remember the last time i seen a
faker skyline than that
wait you see how weird his head looks in
the mask oh dear
came out last year's genderfluid oh
i hope that's doing well for you ann i
really do
it's um
it it's it's been a good journey for me
because the azure playing c was on msc
3k i must do
the joke brick punch hard slam mclarge
huge breakfast
pain
mst 3k is always good for a few good
one-liners
there sure glad i don't look stupid in
this
i don't know many gender fluid people
but you're cool i love your bed
your vids thank you charlie score sounds
cheap as heck yes
sounds like they got a um a four-person
orchestra
uh so how's the movie so far mostly
bland and cheap
it's not bonkers say that
you're beautiful too you're valid to
your love too
thank you
it does help to hear that back sometimes
is that peggy carter i would be
surprised if they keep
that much of the specifics
i mean she's probably the equivalent
do you okay so far i mean doing well
enough
trying to figure out why the waitress
has a gun
did they stumble into a random nazi
[Music]
diner
no they didn't stumble apparently we
have secret
somebodies
okay so i'm guessing this is uh where
they're gonna
they're gonna hit him with the steroids
i'm sorry
super vitamins shh it's steroids
you know knowing how small the budget
had to be this is
surprisingly decently put together so
far
this is a decent set it's not even that
different from the one in uh first
avenger
of course i also think first avenger
isn't very good
remember i'm an englishman so the most
gushy thing i can say is you're pretty
good pal
do you watch reality tv not anymore i
used to
very sporadically
oh
how far from the prologue have we moved
from because otherwise it's going to be
kid is red skull i think
i think it was six years i don't know i
wasn't paying that much attention
you watch rupaul i do not
for reasons
i wonder if there was any particular
reason
that they
changed the red skull to italian and
um like are having it be
an italian scientist instead of a nazi
scientist
like mussolini was fighting with
with the nazis so i don't i don't know
what the
point of that change would be oh
i can guess they probably secured
filming locations
in italy
if i were to guess did you watch the
mandalorian i watched the first season i
do not currently have intentions to
watch the second
there are uh
people on the show i'm not particularly
comfortable
watching
[Music]
oh i forgot about that
because yes i've seen the nostalgia
critic review
oh wow
on the nose about the reason for the
country changing aha see
i know canon films in their methods
oh there's the thing of the clown the
criminal or the comedian
i'm fluid i can be all three
um
this is exactly what i needed tonight
i'm happy to help
like that this is a distraction for me
but i'm hoping that like anyone watching
will get like some just
ha out of this
and he gets out of the hospital bed
because captain america
i love your laugh thank you very much
wow that mask is really blue
i really blew
wow okay
so they're just we're just gonna track
him on his first mission
he's already got at least part of the
outfit
he's already got the shield like we're
just we're just not gonna cover any of
these bases
they're just like ah you know the rest
i think it was comedian chameleon
corinthian and caricature
uh it's funny you mentioned corinthian
because i have been listening to the
um the sandman audio
and the corinthian is one of the few
vocal performances i don't really care
for and i realized why
uh time stamp uh 18 minutes
so
the reason that i didn't like the
corinthians
vocal performance in the um sandman
audiobook
and why i was nitpicking it is the same
reason that i was nitpicking desire
which is because those are the
characters i would want to play and i
get
very particular on performances for
characters that i wish i could play
who lived within a fight superman or
captain america i mean superman
like the whole like i know they've
actually done specials out of it but the
whole idea of dc versus marvel is
ridiculous because comparatively dc
are so overpowered compared to marvel
it's insane
i the the observation has been made
before
that marvel tells story about people who
gain
powers and dc tell stories about gods
among people
the power levels certainly bear that out
greedy yes i can be
caroline uh me too that's why i nitpick
all versions of the master
not fair wow that outfit
whoa
okay oh dear
oh dear you make a great beast
adam and beauty and the beast i'm
flattered
i'm watching the feathers on the side of
this thing just
bob around
she glanced this way and then i saw him
and when we touched she didn't shudder
at my paw
okay i'll stop
would it be a right to pause every so
often to sync up keep getting bogged
down by abrasive yeah i'm hitting them
too
um so i'm currently at
uh 2040.
huh i mean
low budget 1990 that's an
okay-ish red skull
[Laughter]
okay the voice though oh an american
uh on a scale of one to ten how
protective are you of some people it
depends on the people there some people
i will jump straight up to ten on
not many but some
i also think you make a great bill ah in
my version she's the technomancer
i swear those are rubber ears uh yeah
they are
yeah that was uh that was a bit of
trivia i knew about this
those are not his ears sticking out of
that mask
they are rubber ears
uh
feathered heroes the pain of your
existence tonight does seem to be that
way
i also make a good valjean and les mis i
would prefer javert
although i say that and i hate stars i
don't think that's a good song
i think it kills the pace of the show
dead
um but other than that i like jeff air
valjean key goes to way too high for me
i cannot hit
some of those notes
did they strap him to a rocket
so he chopped off his own hand
and captain america is strapped to a
very cheap looking rocket
get shot throws a man into a bloody
generator gets
grabbed with a hidden saint d click
nah knocked the hell out yeah this is a
little um
strap him to a rocket is this riverdale
i knew about that plot
i don't watch riverdale but liz loves to
tell me about the insanity
of that show
it'd be good uh luis and kiss the spider
woman i still need to see that
i haven't seen that um
[Music]
and i i would be hesitant to
go for that um say i'd be good at that
because
i i know that traditionally the
character's been played by
um latinx actors
and i uh i don't know if it's written
specifically to be that definitely if it
is that's not
like a step back from that
um make a good bach and wicked
he gets tracked to the rocket are you
sure it's captain america and not
not goodbye mr ray um
do you have any unpopular opinions i'm
sure i do
i don't keep track i mean aside from the
fact that i hate the shining
and i think david tennant's doctor is
overrated i mean those are the two
best known ones at this point
oh god he's still on the rocket
and he's he's what he's just
he diverted the rocket
by kicking it
[Music]
the effect of this thing landing
oh oh lord
would you ever play seymour in little
shop of horrors ah
at six feet tall i think i'm a hard sell
to see more
i'd like to think that i could play the
part but um
given that i'm usually taller than most
of the people on the stage it's hard to
project the
picked on nerd when you're looking down
at everybody else
oh good early 90s child actors
everybody's favorite
tennis doctor doesn't make my top five
yet i find him possibly the most
interesting as a character
yeah i find him too predictable
hey how many people uh look uh look over
christopher eccleston's doctor however
at least tenants doctor had donna
i still maintain that series four is the
best series of revived doctor who
did i miss something the landing looked
fine it was the sound effect and like
how clearly it was a model
this very limp bounce that it had
peace you have to announce it in big
bold letters with
with an exclamation uh
we're just vamping our way through
through the decades and now i've got
hiccups
oh damn it
oh pups here no
what did you miss well you missed the
entirety of howard the duck
went up oh i'm now currently watching
the 1990 captain america
it's free on youtube
oh 28 and a half minutes in
there was a recent controversy over the
giant little pill musical that's a thing
over a cis woman playing a non-binary
character
like with all do due respect to whoever
the actress is because i'm sure it's not
her fault she was cast in the part it
was a decision made
by the directors but there should be
controversy there are non-binary actors
there are non-binary stage actors there
are non-binary
film and tv actors if they
claim if they claim they didn't
find one then i would say they didn't
look very hard i would say
much more likely i didn't try very hard
at all
would you ever review glee that one you
would have to pay me
ow what i hate most about the hiccups
is that they hurt when i get hiccups
they like they
ah ow they actually hurt
so it's not just annoying it's painful
oh
ronnie cox i immediately don't trust him
i've seen movies
second time you got hiccups on a live
stream yes and last time it was a good
omen
so you know
wow
oh and the generals the
the old man from uh the christmas story
it's cute when you get the hiccups i'm
glad you folks enjoy it
howard the duck equals hiccups oh boy
so the
so the red skull's just been kicking a
wrap around
for 45 years
just for shits and giggles
if your hiccups get worse should i fetch
a duck tour
if nightmare before christmas ever makes
it broadway you could play jack i could
play zero
zero and five feet ah that works
duck puns of the daleks oh
you hurt me the lot of you
what's up with your face life's been
good to me yeah like i'm trying to
figure out
because like it's not a secret that he's
the red skull they opened the scene
where they were saying back when that
was known as the dead skull
so like they know who he is so what's
the point of like
half hiding his face but like not really
because you can tell
that like his
face is still messed up like what what's
the point of any of that
who's the shortest person in the stream
i'm 5'3 you're 5'3
pup
i could use you as a shoulder rest i
wouldn't that's
rude but i could
hocus pocus or nightmare before
christmas oh nightmare
hocus poc controversial
opinion for people my age
hocus pocus isn't very good
like it's fun don't get me wrong i get
why people like it
but it's not actually very very good
five foot three five foot six five one
geez you i am way taller than like
all of you five eleven
i think catherine's gonna should beat
miss ms wiggin wolf
at uh four eleven
five ten there's somebody
six six seven
six foot seven
oh [ __ ]
the the music on this is so lame
this is a fate scene as ralphie
remember christmas story went on to be
in iron man
and spider-man far from home did he
who who is he
nathanial to 10th doctor fans your waifu
is trash
i fit well in places i believe you
oh mcdonald's burger king or wendy's
honestly it all tastes the same to me
i don't eat fast food very often
oh
there's no reason for a person to be
above
six foot we have cranes for that stop it
that's enough vertical
real estate
i'm so sorry you have to get a step
stool
a box of scraps guy uh
ralphie uh was the guy that obadiah
stain yelled
oh that guy i didn't realize that was
peter billingsley tony stark built this
in a cave
with a box of scraps so that's why
somebody said box of scraps guy okay
i wasn't making connections i i'm
hydrated
captain america
why is your water in a can because it's
fancy thank you very much lucy
um staying up to watch you
uh know what
know what in the uk hope you're doing
well
i'm doing okay having a good time
watching this
being with you folks this this is a good
way to spend my evening
oh my god
what are your thoughts on home alone one
and two i have not rewatched either
in a long time as a kid i liked home
alone too better because
the comedy was more over the top as i
got a little bit older i appreciated
that one
had way better structure and two was
very much just a retread just
trying to up the whole thing
size doesn't matter it's how we use it
like people say that
i'm just saying
size can matter
especially if you know how to use it
somebody's gonna clip that and declare
me a size queen now
ah are you sure you're not drunk i'm
pretty sure
i'm not these damn hiccups though
favorite beetle mine is george harrison
i don't have a favorite
beetle i don't even get that way about
bands like who who's your favorite
member of this band i'm like i don't
i like the ba the music of the the band
like i don't ah
what are your thoughts on a christmas
story that one was odd for me because
i um i didn't grow up watching it i
didn't see until i was an
it's pretty good though it's it's got a
really unique
tone and flavor to it it's a it's a nice
piece of work
thoughts on polar express it's not a
movie it's a roller coaster
ride like you can tell the way it shot
it with that
like it's got all the tackiest 3d
gimmickry
and that's before you even get to the
uncanny valley of the whole thing like
it's just
why size queens of the daleks
no comments
oh
thoughts on elf uh the climax kind of
sucks but
other than that it's fine
what do you think of police academy i've
never seen any of those
movies
god that outfit looks really terrible
i'm not following what the hell is going
on at all
like i don't know who this woman is
that's trying to kill captain america
how she found him i don't know who ned
beatty is and how he
got to where captain america was
i i don't i can't follow what's going on
at all
not that it's confusing i'm sure it's
perfectly straightforward but like i'm
this is this is hard to pay attention my
eyes
slide off this this movie
christmas story live uh has a good joke
with the chinese choir
being actually pretty good in the old
main goal i wasn't expecting that
that's good because that joke that is
one joke that like ooh
damn
the polar express and or christmas carol
2009
ah probably christmas carol
has yeah not by much
and the owner folding his arms going
well what were you expecting
oh that that's good rowan i like that
the woman is red skull's daughter yeah
because with a face like that i'm sure
he was getting all kinds of tail
makes about as much sense as palpatine
having kids
um
this movie has a perception filter it
very well might
nathaniel saying captain america and red
skull's italian accent made me laugh
uncontrollably
what you mean captain america
did you hear that abc is not playing
charlie brown specials anymore
no i didn't hear that
huh
i remember hearing about this is where
he steals the car
why though this guy's like on his
side why is he gonna steal the
uh
trust me christmas story live isn't
worth it matthew broderick is the
narrator is terribly wouldn't oh
yeah thoughts on mars needs mom never
saw it
don't want to oh thank you pup
i like to match up palpatine got with a
beautiful woman while
in his gross form imagine the noise he'd
make the mohn's
cinema oh yes
feel the power of the dark suck
i'd
he suspects he's an enemy because he's
driving a german car oh
thank you i'm glad some of you people
are paying more attention to me
to me than me and filling me in
that was everything i wanted from rise
of skywalker
oh have you ever heard of pippin the
musical heard of it yes
like i don't even know what it's about
uh uh excuse me
are you all right with the hiccups i'm
i'll survive they suck
but what is this song
that they're playing if anyone needed
the time check
44 and a half minutes in what is this
song
oy
what is this what is this song poundland
springs scene
sounds accurate all they had to do when
rise of skywalker would say palpatine
used the dark side of the forest to
create life in a woman's womb and he
created both ryan anakin
or you know they could just not bring
palpatine back
crazy idea the guy who was in no way
hinted at still being alive in either
of the previous two films maybe just let
him stay freaking
dead
you're drinking i have switched to
to uh down east original blend i am
still on downey
cider they they do good work
[Music]
what's your favorite christmas song
um
we three kings
no that's my second favorite carol the
bells carol the bells are my favorite
disney out jokered the joker
uh
you sounded like mark hamill reading
episode nine script
god and he's still in the freaking
costume under that trench
coat where did he even get the trench
coat
ian mcdormand is good in dirty rotten
scoundrels and welcome to hell
i've seen bits of dirty run scoundrels
i don't know welcome to hell what was
carol
of the bells again
it has words but i actually prefer
acoustic versions for the most part
have you ever heard trans siberian
orchestra's version of the caro the
bells
heard it
ah senior year high school
talent show i danced
to it
and i won the dance category
the more i hear about rise of skywalker
the more pleased i am i gave it a miss
yeah look i i kind of had the opposite
experience of um
[Music]
the last jedi i came out of the last
jedi
going i don't know what i think of that
and leaning negative
um and sort of over time
seeing some of the merits in it but
still not liking it
and then with the rise of skywalker i
came out of it not knowing entirely what
i thought but leaning positive
but not able to defend it at all
like it's a disaster like i you can make
a defense
i still don't like the last jedi i will
never like the last jedi
but you can and people have make
good defenses of it there are things to
defend there are cases to be made there
really is no
defense of rise of skywalker i just came
out of it and i'm like well it didn't
piss me off
so i gave it a pass at the time wait
you're a skilled dancer
skilled is um skilled is a
strong word i am not trained
and yes you're right that aging effect
is um
well it's of the time it is very 1990.
um
there's a good acapella version of carol
the bells done by
the georgian gory women's choir entitled
the little swallow
i'm actually really enjoying this red
skull's voice like not that it's good
but it's like i'm
amused by it so
you have discovered these things
put it surprised twice
she looks familiar though the woman
playing
his daughter is she anybody
somebody look that up
what are your thoughts on pentatonix
they're uh a cappella group right
i don't know them particularly like i do
enjoy acapella but like i don't follow
it
like i'm old so my point of reference
for acapella is
the nylons and rocapella so
do it rocapella
where in the world is carmen sandiego
apparently jim carrey was originally
intended to play the eighth doctor but
he turned it down because he didn't know
the show
citation needed
on that one
there are other ways they could have
gotten episode nine back on track like
have snoke survive and just saying luke
teleported away at the end of last jedi
look here's the main thing breathing
nerdum um
the main thing that they had to do to
write
the ship for episode nine was delay the
movie
because the time from when colin
trevorrow bailed and
they completely scrapped his treatment
like threw it out and started over
there was never gonna be enough time for
them to make their release date
that they decided they weren't gonna
move
they um they needed to delay the movie
at least a year
for them for so that they could work the
script
but they didn't
captain america's in california
like don't accuse me of doing a race
success accent i'm imitating them
uh you're not old 40 is not old
first of all i'm not 40 yet
second of all by
by internet standards
i i am old but
by youtube standards i'm not super old
i'm slightly old by youtube standards
i'm on tick tock now i'm damn old for
tick tock
go on citation google it no that's not
how citation works
citation is you provide a source for
your claims
telling me to google it is not citing a
source
this this is me taking a teaching moment
if you are going to say that something
is accurate you must be able to cite a
credible source
google itself is not a credible source
requiring the people asking you to cite
a source
to google it themselves is asking them
to do your research for you that is not
a citation
if you are unprepared to give a citation
that's fine
but don't tell me to google it because
when i asked you to cite me the source
that's your job
francesca neri's that actress she was
also in
uh al modavar's life flesh hannibal and
collateral damage i might have seen her
in hannibal
hannibal the show or the movie
captain america is just like kicking
around watching tv
what is god this is weird
also let's just call spay to spay jj
abrams isn't great he can be good but he
can also be very bad
jj abrams isn't good at endings
he actually seems to go out of his way
to avoid them
just means you're very close to the milf
age of consent
i'm counting down the days until you
turn 40 oh dear
can't stay it's getting late that's all
right camille
thank you for answering my questions so
thank you for the joker impressions i
had a good night
oh thank you for joining us
don't worry everyone's too old for tick
tock
fair
the film she was inspector pozzi's wife
oh yes okay
that is what i know her from thank you
rowan nicely done
that's your job what vera would be like
to work for
um
which is you know why i don't have
employees
i'm not sure i'd be a great boss
uh do you think you're sexy
sometimes i do not always but
i have narcissistic tendencies sometimes
i do
not always though
disney needed to find a director with an
appreciation for star wars who didn't
want to copy it like abrams wanted to
favro seems to
understand with the mandalorian i um
i still think that even abrams could
have delivered something better
if they had taken longer
on the scripting process
like
they had to rush the story development
in the script
to make a release date that's just what
they had to do
and while i
think there's plenty of criticisms to
level at abrams
i severely doubt he was happy with that
movie
i would be shocked if he was if in an
honest interview if he was happy with
that movie
so you actually look really good for
your age
i thank you
i feel sexier as a woman than a man yeah
no
vibe hey my hiccups are gone
is star wars dead in film do you think
uh
it's um it's on a coma it needs a break
the president's been kidnapped no
so
so what he's just gonna he's just gonna
hop a flight to italy
like i know it's 1990 and there's way
less regulations to get on flights but
you still need a passport
steve
do you think you would win a drinking
contest maybe at some point previously
not now
since uh going on hormone regimens i am
more of a lightweight than i used to be
i can drink liz under the table but
she's such a lightweight
most blondes i've met are actually
home cooking and pies
as the genericus looking diner
sorry cafe roz's cafe
folding ideas dissection of trevor's
book of henry's one of my favorite
cinema critiques ever i get cramps
laughing so hard
folding ideas when he wants to pull
something apart
it's a good time
do you ever get drunk new year's eve
yeah
like the thing is i don't get
i don't get fall down drunk anymore i
think the last time i did that was
probably
close to five years ago it was probably
the last time i got
like wasted i don't really do that
anymore
i don't say i don't get drunk but i do
make a distinction between levels of
drunk there are
there are phases of drunk
there are degrees of drunk none of which
should
you should you be driving while in that
state but just saying
i'll just throw his mighty shield no
passport needed
when captain america throws his mighty
shield
i've done i've done a lot of singing the
hearth is still going to get flagged
give me a pepsi free you want a pepsi
pal you gotta pay for it
are you gonna wrap up as soon as the
film ends um
uh probably fairly soon after yeah
oh i do as well abrams was crippled by
the time in his dislike of endings in my
opinion how star wars needs to be
handled
going forward is not copying off its old
the old stuff but respecting it
well i mean like specific circumstances
of uh rise of skywalker aside which
include
losing his previous director not moving
the film back and
losing an actor um
you know losing carrie fisher
the simple fact is that
the last jedi put things in a place
where
it was always going to be difficult to
follow on from not impossible
but difficult and
it didn't help that abram's opted to
just basically
not address a lot of what went on and
last jedi
my overall thoughts on last jedi at this
point was that
for what ryan johnson wanted to do they
should have given him one of the side
films
if he was going to be that
deconstructionist with it they should
have
let him make original characters to do
it with
did you watch disney's adventures of the
gummy bears growing up
if you haven't it's on disney plus um
not regularly
not like i did was say gargoyles
um or even ducktales uh and tailspin
but i like a little i saw it every now
and then
i remember the theme song still gummy
bears bouncing here and there and
everywhere
at least one of these songs is gonna get
this thing flagged i don't know which
one
so does he just grab anything vaguely
shield-shaped and use it as a weapon
yes the answer to that question is yes
this is a very limp
action scene
i was actually at the pub with some
friends and they all raised the glass
for sean connery and not actually
knowing
uh not actually
no he was dead yet he quoted you he can
hit a woman in celebration
[Music]
i did notice there was a lot less of the
sean connery rest in peace
uh in social media than one might have
otherwise expected i suspect
largely because enough people know
sort of the issues with him that they
realize they would have been inviting
people to come in and go like hey this
and so they just left it alone
uh which one do you hate more ferris
bueller the shiny
as a film i hate ferris bueller more
i am way more frustrated with
the shining because it has such a high
reputation as like this
truly great masterpiece and it's
fricking
not it's just not
so like there's additional there's my
feelings on the movies themselves in a
vacuum in which case ferris bueller's
the worst i get i'm
i probably get worked about them on even
footing because what bolsters my issues
with the shining is how high its profile
is
and few things can irritate you like
something that you
don't see the value in everyone going
it's amazing about it you're like
what no
there's an interactive blu-ray film of
batman
death in the family out ooh
interactive do you get to personally
beat jason todd to death what the hell
what does it matter what the red skull
saying when he was a boy was maybe it
does matter i haven't been paying
attention
sorry president dick jones
sorry robocop reference i don't know how
many heads that just went over
um what do you think of the hunger games
trilogy i only you saw the first two
movies i didn't see the last two i
haven't read the book so i can't
give an opinion on the trilogy as a
whole do you think eric roberts's
incarnation of the master would be good
in his own big finish series
i don't know because i need to hear his
big finish appearance that he's already
done and i
haven't yet
a hidden transmitter does it look
something like
this
i still don't understand the point of
altering the makeup
like i just i don't what any thoughts on
robocop
that's uh that's a ballsy movie is what
that
thing is and satirically
vicious darkly hilarious but damn
it's a bander snatch choose what happens
one ew
no
it's kind of interesting given jason
todd was voted to die by comic fans as i
understand it
he was but like
i i don't know that feels gross to me in
a way that i can't even really architect
i articulate
as to why and now he's gonna pull the
exact same thing
because
god his face is so asymmetrical
and like i don't mean like that makes
him a bad person but it's it's
throwing me off
jennifer lawrence along with a lot of
celebrities knew about harvey weinstein
most of hollywood knew about harvey
weinstein like most stuff that goes on
in a company town
it was an open secret same thing as most
of the stuff that goes on in washington
most people that work and live there
know about it they just don't talk about
it
same with hollywood now i'm not saying
that to let anybody off the hook but i'm
just saying i'm pretty sure the list of
people who at least didn't have
who didn't have even an inkling of what
harvey weinstein was like
is way shorter than the list of people
who at least had heard about
if not witnessed and knew for certainty
what he was
i'm just saying
the hunk with non-euclidean features
his lack of a bill disturbs me right
like it's like the face just doesn't
work without without a good proper bill
bonjour italian accents
we have them in the movie
so she just turns up he tricked her into
getting in the car on his own and she
just turns up again the next scene so
that was
pointless
that feels like the real essence of this
movie
pointless
to be honest roberts isn't that bad in
big finish i figure you
probably uh have a better shot there
i know you have previously stated you
love the shape of water but what is your
opinion on gamma del toro's other work i
like his work a lot
the one i probably have the lowest
opinion on is kronos which was his first
film and it's only just because you can
kind of see the seams
on it um and you can tell it's like him
still finding his feet
in some ways it's still good but it's
about the only one that i wouldn't want
to that
i haven't bothered to see more than once
um
i like all his films and i've seen all
of them
he is one of those directors where i
have seen every film he's directed
the guy who does brook cannon davis did
a really interesting
video on interactive media i'm sure
there's interesting things to be said
about it
what's your favorite disney song
part of your world reprise
one film that gave its audience the
choice of whether to kill the main
character they just recorded the ending
where a guy dies because they
knew the crowd would ask for blood
you gotta love a rigged gimmick
is there any is there supposed to be any
tension with this
like with me concerned that he's gonna
find the red skull like
for the big villain of this piece they
have spent
shockingly little
screen time together
i'm suspicious of you and your designer
sunglasses
wow that was the slowest
drawing of guns i have ever seen in a
movie
that was the speed at which these women
drew these guns to try and shoot him
like i've never seen a gun draw that
slow that wasn't a slow motion shot
mine is why should i worry when i'm
upbeat and you'll be in my heart when i
want something comforting why should i
worry is an interesting pick
like um
i i hate to be a downer but like it
really annoyed me that you'll be in my
heart won the oscar
because like
lots of people got on that like oh phil
collins won an oscar against all these
great songs and there were a lot of
great songs in contention
that year at the oscars i wasn't annoyed
that a song from tarzan won i was
annoyed that that specific song from
tarzan won because i thought it was the
least interesting song on the entire
soundtrack for that film
like i if it had been um
[Music]
son of man or strangers like me
or any really any song
other than that i would have been like
no that's fair but i don't know
that one didn't work for me it's the
first time we've seen you yawn
oh might be so he's just been carrying
the shield in his
travel bag
oliver jackson cohen who played peter
quint
from blind manners also scarecrow analog
in
the dark wizard of oz series emerald
city
huh okay what's wrong with you'll be in
your heart
you'll be in my heart honestly
it's just very on the nose
like back let me back up i'll revise
if i remember correctly because i
haven't seen tarzan in a long time
the song starts with tarzan's adoptive
mother scene and when
she's singing it it actually works
really well
but when it goes into phil khan's
singing i think honestly
largely it's his voice i don't think
works for that song
at all like that song sung with a female
voice
okay that's pretty good him singing it
no
and like he's he's the one who sings it
for the vast majority of the song as it
appears in that film
his voice worked for strangers like me
for son of man you know but
they they should have just let her sing
it
but they decided now the characters were
going to break out into song except for
smashing up the camp so
now that song that song's fun
shout out to uh
why the guy he's always just getting
into cars
and stealing like do something
why are you always getting in these
damned lame cars
for me it's hellfire why is it people
think a little girl singing
let it go in public is adorable but when
i sing hellfire it's creepy
hmm ben i i i
can't possibly imagine
if we're going villain songs i gotta
give it to poor unfortunate souls
which is the bonus is in my range so i
can actually
sing it
you can tell that was a bad guy because
he was in black
you'll be in my heart uh was a lullaby
for phil's daughter and khala sings the
whole thing on the broadway version
there's even a prize
um that probably works then
on the broadway version the film version
i don't think works that great
oh would you carolyn
we'll negotiate a price at a later date
oh god this is such a boring car chase
i cannot get excited when he's driving
this little bubble car
uh
seeing that beauty and the beast got
three song nominations later there's no
excuse for part of your world not
getting nominated
yeah legit
poor unfortunate souls sounds like it
was about anyone who watched the movie
howard the duck
come on you pun fortune
soaps oh
for me it's caught between poor
unfortunate souls we prepared mob song
and friends on the other side
friends on the other side's a good one
oh but like ah
keith david's voice
oh
oh that man's voice oh
god i'm okay
i'm okay
which do you prefer why should i worry
or you'll be in my heart between those
two i go with why should i worry
uh well nicholas uh
i am currently watching the 1990 version
of captain america well i'm
barely watching the 1990 version of
captain america it's free on youtube if
you want to join in
i'm closing in on one hour 17 minutes
world's greatest criminal mind is in my
top three i think that's a good one too
listening to keith david sing that song
should have been an early indicator i
wasn't straight
legit
i want to know i want to get some
numbers on how many
eventual furries had their first crush
on
goliath from gargoyles
and keith david's voice
uh have you seen thomas sanders mashup
of disney songs i
don't believe i had
let me yell in italian
then again i could say the same earlier
for tim curry singing toxic love
oh
toxic low gargoyles are not furry i said
eventual furries it's a stepping stone
uh did you ever see ted nealy do jc
superstar i don't
think so i've seen a couple of versions
of that i don't think i've seen that
ronnie cox is trying so hard to
to just act in this scene and it's
he's just overdoing it because i'm
pretty sure they had
no real direction he's just like ah
to be honest the incarnation of the
master that needs their own series the
most is
gordon tipple uh the stand-in from the
start
uh of the tv movie
are you tired a little i am probably
gonna wrap it up fairly soon after this
ends
is someone i'm quite fond of having
trouble with the name peter collins i
think
peter cullen would be the voice of
optimus prime
transform and roll out i can't actually
do an impression of that i can't
even go that deep have you seen the
worst witch featuring tim curry i have
not
it's a shame the red skull's makeup
seems to be the highest budgeted aspect
of the film only to be utilized in a
small five-minute segment
yes seriously they had a decent makeup
why wouldn't they use it
i love that captain america says i'm not
gonna blow it this time basically
acknowledging that this entire movie
is an hour and 20 minute build up for
him trying to
succeed in the mission he failed at 45
years ago
hmm
am i the only one who likes red skull's
makeup it seems appropriately sinister
it's not that it's bad it's actually
fine i just don't know why they dropped
the full red for this
jigsaw looking thing i say jigsaw i
don't mean jigsaw killer from
the saw movies i mean jigsaw like jigsaw
the punisher villain
if they cast you as pt barnum in the
broadway version of the greatest showman
would you do it
frick yeah
gonna go now bye have a good night
charlie thanks for sticking with me as
long as you did
what's your favorite disney villain
demise what was the most appropriate one
um
oh i have to think about that when i'm
not
tired and hydrated
so the president's solution was to kill
himself
and just by dumb luck captain america
happened to be there
okay to quote tony stark
not a great plan
it actually looked good in a top hat and
a long red coat in the came
i have a top hat i also have a cane
i don't have a ringmaster's coat though
gee whiz captain america
just said gee
whiz
the stand-in actually did a monologue
for the opening of the tv movie as the
master
which uh outside the american accent
sounds quite
eerie yeah
one of my favorites was facilia's
getting dragged to hell that one was
harsh for a kid's movie
it's funny when you say it what gee whiz
he said it three times uh i mean i'd
like i have not been paying attention
i love how he he captain america's way
of coming
into view of the bad guys is to just
jump out with the shield in front of him
oh god
oh gee whiz
i shouldn't have done a close-up on his
ear yeah
and oliver and company sites gets killed
by getting run over by an oncoming train
yup yes he does
two possible reasons for princess and
the frog now making that much money are
both depressing
i mean i'm assuming one is the
presumption that 2d
hand drawn just doesn't do as well or
didn't at the time
if there's another reason i don't know
what it is
how is he such a fan of cap was captain
america well known in this version he
failed this one mission
i like the
i forget the specifics but like cap
the kid saw him i
i can't remember now so it's like he
personally saw him
that's why he's such a fan
hey there's no tension in this
confrontation at
all
the other possible reason which i hope
wasn't the case is racism
ah
i doubt that is the driving reason
that might have been the reason why
certain people didn't give it its due
but i don't think that would have been a
box office reason
at least i personally don't think so do
you like hot chocolate yeah i want them
in the mood
i deal with peppermint schnapps
i like trains
[Laughter]
uh they're trying to have a cool fight
with the
red skull but like it's so obvious that
they don't have decent stunt worker
choreography because like
every every punch thrown is
is a new cut they're covering so much
for the fact that these guys can't fight
and they didn't have a good stun
team
that is the plastickiest looking
shield that thing i might fall asleep to
the sound of this your voice is like a
snarky lullaby
uh who do you feel would be more of a
heavyweight drinker missy or the 12th
doctor
missy would drink him under the table
do you hum
sometimes not habitually
steve you're frisbee
oh
that that that
right there made it all worth it
this whole boring thing for that
moment of captain america going
mr president thanks
[Laughter]
oh oh my goodness
oh friends on the other side was a
moment that made me realize randy newman
doesn't always write the same song was
he the songwriter on the
princess and the frog
[Laughter]
oh do you prefer singing whistling or
humming
singing when i'm um feeling in tune
what are your thoughts on jawbreaker i
never saw that one
time stamp the time stamp for that was
probably around an hour 28.
why is there a piano on top of this fort
and a grand piano like what
why is that there
hey okay mr president thanks for placing
the cavity as your clothes out
it might tonight
with a bomb and there's a bomb in the
piano
why is there a bomb in a pier
so now he's just gonna fire his gun in
the into the air randomly
yes
big enough to radiate all southern
europe but it fits in a piano
let's see like a 60s batman villain yeah
a bit and that is the weirdest damn
timer i've ever seen
well some days you just can't get rid of
a bomb
just one more second says captain
america
20 seconds later
do you like puns
i tolerate puns
so
he knocked him off the castle to his
death
fine
how did that
stop the bomb because to my
understanding he wasn't holding a
detonator he was holding a
timer wouldn't the timer still go off
whatever
either once you love me from toy story 2
or blame cara
canada should have won instead of you'll
be in my heart when she loved me
should've won
that song breaks me
did you tolerate me when i was making
those puns i did because it was in good
humor
so if you're tolerant there will be no
punishment
do you like bacon on occasion ultimate
frisbee the movie yeah pretty much
thanks
peter that was honestly
that was just
lame
that's that's that's the only word i've
got for it
all right i need to wrap up i am beat
i'm tired and if i stay up i'll start
looking at election crap and i don't
want to i want to get a good night's
sleep so
thank you for joining me i hope i
provided an
entertaining distraction for you fine
fine people
could have been worse you could have
been watching the emoji movie i've seen
that movie
how are the duck far more exciting i
mean
it was livelier i'll tell you that much
ah
okay so i'm gonna wrap it up thanks
everybody for tuning in
thanks for being here everybody stay
safe
out there and
no matter what is going on right now or
what
is going on in the morning or what is
going on the rest of this week because
realistically we are not going to have
accurate numbers
on the polls for several days if not
weeks so no matter what
do something every day
to help make it a good day
because even with everything going on
you can still find things
to do or people to see or things to
experience or comforts to
partake in that can make it a good day
so as best as you are able to make each
day a good day
we'll get through it thank you for
watching
you're beautiful you're valid
you are loved you are the council
i just run the meetings mr president
thanks my cavity